et avec nous aujourd'hui Erick Revel
bonjour et Gretel merci beaucoup d'être
invitation de la publication de la revue
les missile et Pablo pilot Vivien nous a
rejoint bonjour Pablo rédacteur
Quentin évidemment était avec nous quand
on va venir
le fond Marianne la commission d'enquête
sanatoriale au cœur de ces travaux
audition très tendue hier de Mohamed
Sifaoui le principal bénéficiaire du
fond et de Marlène Schiappa mercredi la
ministre à l'origine de ce fond qui est
en difficulté devant les sénateurs
Quentin on verra les temps forts de ses
auditions et on verra avec vous s'il
peut y avoir des conséquences politiques
pour Emmanuel Macron pour son
gouvernement mais aussi pour la
démocratie est-ce que cette affaire peut
creuser un peu plus le fossé entre les
Français et les politiques on en
débattra et puis à la fin de cette
émission on vous emmène prendre un grand
bol d'air dans le parc des écrins qui
est faite ses 50 ans vous verrez ce
reportage de Samia de Schir dans une
demi-heure d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'info dans nos régions du côté de
Saint-Étienne on est en duplex avec
Gilles Artigues bonjour Gilles Artigues
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
duplex depuis les locaux de nos
partenaires de TL7 la télévision locale
de Saint-Etienne qu'on remercie beaucoup
pour ce duplex j'ai l'article vous êtes
en sien première adjoint en mer de
Saint-Étienne il y a 10 mois éclaté une
affaire deux chantages à la sextape
provoqué qui a provoqué pas mal de
remous c'est le cas de c'est peu de le
dire à la mairie de Saint-Étienne Gilles
Artigues avant de vous entendre et on
vous remercie d'être avec nous on va
voir le résumé de cette affaire avec
Flora sauvage
le scandale éclate en août 2022 mais en
réalité l'affaire remonte à 2015 quand
Gilles Artigues premier adjoint sans
triste à la mairie de Saint-Étienne est
filmé à son insu dans une chambre
d'hôtel en train de se faire masser par
un escort boy ce rendez-vous intime
aurait été organisé par un autre élu
municipal de la majorité samiquait
figerome le chantage commence alors et
Gilles Artigues décide d'enregistrer les
menaces pendant 8 ans le premier adjoint
va rester dans le silence avant de
déposer plainte 7 mois après les
révélations de Mediapart le maire LR de
Saint-Étienne est mis en examen pour
chantage à la sextape visant à
neutraliser son premier adjoint si Gaël
perdrio est soupçonné d'être le
commanditaire de cette vidéo il a
toujours clamé son innocence exclu de
son parti les républicains après sa
première garde à vue l'élu ne participe
plus aux réunions de travail mais il n'a
pas renoncé à son mandat à la tête de la
ville de Saint-Étienne et à la
présidence de la métropole
et j'ai l'article merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous dis-moi après les premières
révélations vous avez donc choisi de
prendre la parole hier sur France 2 dans
tel sur TL7 évidemment dans cette
affaire de chantage à la sextape
pourquoi prendre la parole maintenant
il a fallu du temps pour moi
en travaillant avec des médecins pour
que je puisse mettre des mots sur ce que
j'ai vécu pendant de nombreuses années
ce chantage cette machination ensuite
les révélations médiatiques et puis
maintenant je pense que je suis prêt
pour m'exprimer je voulais aussi que la
justice est avancée et on a eu à la fois
les garde à vue mais aussi les mises en
examen et mon statut de victime reconnu
de manière officielle
vous avez expliqué vous dites que vous
avez traversé cette année de cauchemars
vous allez même jusqu'à parler de
torture est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
surmonté tout ça
non je n'ai pas surmonté tout cela c'est
vrai que pendant toutes ces années je ne
voyais pas d'issue je n'en parlais à
personne parce que je pensais qu'on ne
pouvait pas me croire j'étais dans une
impasse totale les propos qui mettaient
tenus dans le bureau du maire en
présence de son directeur de cabinet
était d'une extrême violence puisque
même mes enfants étaient menacés d'être
harcelé en particulier puisqu'on disait
que ces images pouvaient être donnés aux
parents des élèves qui se trouvaient
dans la même classe que donc on se remet
pas facilement de cette affaire d'autant
plus que le maire continue à dire que
ce que j'ai avancé n'est pas la vérité
alors que dans cette affaire on n'est
pas parole contre parole il y a des
aveux il y a également des
enregistrements qui prouvent d'une
manière claire le guet-apens et le piège
pour vous ça ne fait aucun doute la
justice n'est pas passée on n'a pas
tranché on le redit mais pour vous ça ne
fait aucun doute que Gaëlle perdrio et
le commanditaire de cette vidéo
non je ne dis pas ça je ne sais pas qui
est le commanditaire je sais ce qu'il
m'a fait subir je sais que lorsque je
lui ai dit que Samy qui est Jérôme
l'adjoint à l'éducation m'avait piégé il
m'a écouté il n'a rien dit et même pire
quelques semaines après lorsque nous
avions eu un petit différent après une
réunion du conseil de majorité il m'a
dit que je ne devrais plus jamais être
en désaccord avec lui sinon bien sûr il
diffuserait les images de qu'il
connaissaient donc
il m'a fait chanter il m'a fait souffrir
ça c'est une réalité et la justice la
bien reconnu puisque on ne met pas en
examen s'il n'y a pas de fait grave et
concordant il a un contrôle judiciaire
également il a payé une caution de 60
000 euros pour ne pas aller en prison
donc on peut pas dire que qu'il n'y a
rien donc bien sûr qui il est un des
acteurs de cette terrible histoire
de l'Intérieur qu'elle perdrio vous le
connaissez vous avez conquis la mairie
de Saint-Étienne ensemble en binôme
est-ce que vous vous attendiez à ça
non pas du tout en 2014 j'avais renoncé
à mes propres ambitions pour me ranger
derrière lui nous avions un accord un
accord entre la droite et le centre que
je représentais il n'aurait jamais été
maire sans moi et au lieu de m'en être
reconnaissant à la première seconde où
il a été élu il a réfléchi avec son
directeur de cabinet à la meilleure
façon de m'éliminer et avec la
complicité de cet adjoint l'éducation et
de son compagnon de l'époque ils ont
pensé à ce barbouzage demeure et l'ont
mis à exécution et ensuite j'ai subi ces
menaces pendant toutes ces années et ça
a été terrible vous dites en examen il
est sous contrôle judiciaire est-ce
qu'il peut continuer à être maire de
Saint-Étienne selon vous
alors oui il peut continuer mais
s'il aimait vraiment Saint-Étienne je
pense qu'il prendrait une autre décision
qui se mettrait en retrait parce que
cette affaire paralyse totalement les
affaires de la vie les conseils
municipaux ne se déroulent pas
normalement les stéphanois a une énorme
majorité lui demande de laisser son
siège alors il tient le coup avec des
élus à qui doit faire des promesses
peut-être des menaces des gens qui
défendent l'indéfendables alors qu'ils
ont entendu quand même les la manière
dont il
menaçaient ils ont entendu aussi des
réunions dans lesquelles j'étais humilié
mais il s'accroche encore à leur poste
menaces des élus Gaëlle perdrio
bah écoutez je ne comprends pas pourquoi
il y a encore cette petite trentaine
d'élus qui lui reste fidèle il y a parmi
eux des gens qui me doivent beaucoup de
choses je les ai accompagnés
[Musique]
c'est délégations à de mes collègues
Lionel boucher qui a
osé dire les choses
oser publiquement demander aux maires se
retirer le maire lui a enlevé ses
délégations et le 26 juin il y aura un
conseil municipal pour décider ou non de
sa destitution d'adjoint et je compte
sur un sursaut de la part de ses élus
pour qu'ils soient vraiment en accord
avec leur conscience
qui vous concerne vous quel est votre
avenir
votre
soit je n'y pense pas il faut que je me
reconstruise avant tout que je protège
ma famille qui m'a toujours soutenue
dans cette affaire et puis je souhaite
mener un autre combat qui
consiste à faire en sorte que ce que
j'ai subi les souffrances que j'ai
endurées puissent être utile aux autres
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai lancé
une plateforme un site internet de lutte
contre le chantage à l'image intime elle
de C2i pour recueillir des témoignages
parce que je suis sûr que ce que j'ai
vécu d'autres l'ont vécu dans les
milieux économiques politiques bien sûr
mais aussi des des médias du sport et de
la culture et il y a un contessablement
nécessité de recueillir ces témoignages
d'envisager peut-être des actions
collectives pourquoi pas également de
solliciter les les parlementaires j'ai
des contacts avec les la sénatrice
Nathalie Coulet avec Hervé Marseille
pour que la loi évolue pour que la
justice soit plus sévère ou et plus
rapide parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ont été faites pour les ados
et c'est très bien parce qu'il y a des
dangers sur les réseaux sociaux très
forts mais pour les personnes plus âgées
dans ces lieux de pouvoir pour l'instant
il n'y a rien et c'est donc mon nouveau
combat
merci j'ai l'article merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin et on
remercie grandement Alice Canivet toutes
les équipes de TL7 qui ont évidemment
permis la réalisation de ce duplex merci
à vous un mot Pablo pilotien peut-être
sur cette affaire oui juste
rajouter en fait un mot qui a pas été
utilisé par Gilles Artigues mais lorsque
on l'écoute lorsque on lit aussi le
récit de son histoire c'est le mot
homophobie c'est à dire que il y a une
homophobie latente dans les le discours
qui est porté par Gilles perdriaux
perdrio pardon lorsqu'il menace de
révéler cette sextape c'est certes une
image intime mais c'est aussi une image
intime d'un homme marié avec un autre
homme enfin un homme marié et dans la
dans la vidéo c'est avec un escort boy
donc il y a aussi ça qui est derrière
cette affaire de de Saint-Étienne après
c'est sûr que ça montre aussi ce que ce
que peut faire en fait l'appétit du
pouvoir de la du maire de Saint-Étienne
si jamais il est jugé responsable bien
sûr pour l'instant
exactement la petite du pouvoir ça peut
ça peut pousser à à beaucoup beaucoup de
perversion et de et de et de choses
terribles comme ça était le cas pour
penger l'article on va parler du fond
Marianne c'est l'actualité politique de
la semaine ici au Sénat on va revenir
d'abord Quentin avec vous sur
les tes auditions du fond Marianne on
rappelle c'est un fond qui a été créé
après l'assassinat de Samuel Patti c'est
Marlène Schiappa qui est à l'origine de
ce fond c'est Mohamed Sifaoui qui est le
président de l'association qui en a été
la principale bénéficiaire tous deux
étaient auditionnés au Sénat cette
semaine cruciale donc une semaine
cruciale vous le dites et on va regarder
les temps forts de ces auditions on va
d'abord parler de celle de Mohamed
Sifaoui c'était hier sous tension
absolument et puis c'est vrai que
c'était l'une des dernières en fait même
la dernière du cycle d'audition des
sénateurs qui ont terminé en fait leurs
auditions et donc le dernier convoqué
c'est lui les séistes Mohamed seafaoui
il était le responsable éditorial de la
principale association bénéficiaire du
fond Marianne son association et celle
qui en fait interroge le plus les
sénateurs on peut le dire et
effectivement une audition émaillée de
sortie de route que nous ont dit les
sénateurs présents dans la salle de
l'audition hier écoutez un exemple un
extrait
vous faites un raccourci malheureux vous
ne comparez à Madame Chapat je n'ai
absolument rien absolument pas ce que
j'ai mis sur le fond ni sur la forme
c'est clair alors d'abord vous n'avez
pas de ni d'ordre ni je vous demande
excusez-moi je pense que vous devez
garder et vos nerfs et votre maîtrise
nous essayons de le faire et poursuivons
et je vous le dis je suis quelqu'un vous
savez je suis quelqu'un d'assez entier
je respecte les institutions et je
respecte les gens qui me respectent mais
j'ai le moment où on me respecte plus je
vais aller sur un autre temps je vous le
dis tout de suite
l'ambiance qui s'est tendue comme cela à
plusieurs reprises dans cette audition
hier
du fonctionnement du fond Marianne quand
bien sûr qui explique avoir été incité à
postuler pour bénéficier du fond
Marianne et c'est vrai que avant-hier
Marlène Schiappa elle elle s'était
défendue de tout favoritisme en faveur
de l'association de ma metifaoui
renvoyant envers le comité de sélection
du fond Marianne l'intellectuel hier et
bien et dont l'analyse a été voilà loué
dans les années 2020-2021 et bien il dit
que tous ces jouets lorsqu'il a croisé
Marlène Schiappa au ministère de
l'Intérieur en marge d'un rendez-vous
qu'il avait avec le cabinet de Marlène
Schiappa et nous sommes à ce moment-là
avant l'appel d'offres du fond Marianne
écouter son témoignage
quand ta minute sort pour vous saluer et
pour vous dire je compte sur vous
est-ce que c'est encouragé à mettre en
application un projet ou pas les
conseillers de la ministre vous disent
la ministre apprécie énormément le
projet que vous nous avez présenté
elle croit en ce projet elles sont
inspirent énormément
et vous encourage à le présenter et à le
et le défendre
quand on va revenir évidemment sur la
suite de ces auditions notamment Marlène
Schiappa mais d'abord Eric Revel sur ce
qui s'est passé hier et on a vu cette
audition très tendue devant les
sénateurs c'est rare une audition comme
ça devant le Sénat c'est oui c'est très
rare moi ce qui me frappe c'est
l'arrogance de Ahmed syfaoui je vous le
dis comme je le pense que j'ai écouté
avec beaucoup d'intérêts cette audition
c'est c'est son arrogance c'est aussi la
façon dont finalement il se défaut sur
Marlène Schiappa c'est à dire ma grande
erreur c'est de lui avoir fait confiance
c'est quand même des mots extrêmement
forts alors on reviendra sur l'audition
qui a pas aussi parce que elle elle se
défaut sur sélection sur
l'administration etc c'est absolument
frappant sur la forme l'arrogance avec
laquelle monsieur Sifaoui répond au
rapporteur et au président de la
commission d'enquête mais si vous le
permettez moi ce qui me choque le plus
dans l'affaire du fond Marianne sont
deux choses la première c'est captais-tu
des détournement de fonds indirect parce
que quand vous êtes payé pour travailler
contre le séparatisme
et que vous faites trois vidéos et demi
et 4 tweets tout mouillé le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que vous en avez pas
pour votre argent ça c'est l'aspect
financier mais l'aspect moral aussi
parce que ce fond il a été créé en
mémoire de Samuel Paty je rappelle en
mémoire de Samuel Pathé donc à
l'occasion si vous voulez si vous voulez
le côté éthique le côté éthique de
l'utilisation des fonds sous couvert
d'une cause terrible et qui a tellement
frappé le pays sur assassinat la
décapitation de Monsieur Paty ces deux
aspects là sont terrifiants sont
terrifiants pour la politique son
terrifiant pour la politique en France
quand vous voyez le taux d'abstention
qu'on voyait le désintérêt des Français
pour la politique à partir de faits
comme cela on peut pas on peut pas trop
s'étonner finalement et on va revenir
évidemment sur la question du
séparatisme mais ce que vous avez
soulevé Eric Revel c'est une des
questions aussi c'est qu'est-ce qui a
été fait de ces fonds qu'elle a été la
production de ces associations et
notamment celle de Mohamed Sifaoui
est-ce que là on a des réponses
d'ailleurs on a une animation que on
peut vous concentrer sur le projet
hilaïque ou highlike c'est le en fait le
principal projet qui avait monté cette
association dont Mohamed cifaoui était
le responsabilité éditorial et regardez
c'est un projet qui avec des centaines
de millions d'euros de budget simplement
à qui
1763 abonnés sur trois réseaux sociaux
donc Twitter TikTok Instagram 500
publications sur ces trois plateformes
et d'ailleurs et bien le comité
interministériel qui dotait les
associations du fond Marianne révèle
lui-même dans un bilan que malgré une
stratégie de publication régulière vous
le voyez en rouge l'engagement en ligne
a été faible d'où cette interrogation
sur à quoi a servi le financement la
subvention du fond Marianne envers cette
usbpm cette association dont la maladie
était le responsable éditorial et ça
fait partie des questions évidemment à
quoi services se font et pourquoi il y a
pas eu peut-être plus de contrôle sur la
production de ces associations
c'est le coeur c'est le cœur du sujet et
c'est ce que met en lumière l'affaire
autour de ce fond Marianne c'est à dire
que les les ministres les élus les
d'ailleurs à tous les niveaux ça marche
aussi dans les mairies ne peuvent pas
faire n'importe quoi en fait avec
l'argent public ils ne peuvent pas le
donner comme ça à leurs amis ou ou juste
le donner sans contrôle sans
véritablement savoir parce que c'est ce
qui a mis en avant Marlène schia Parman
japa à toutes les questions elles
disaient bonjour j'en sais rien je sais
pas peut-être mais peut-être pas donc et
Mohamed cifaoui moi j'aimerais juste
revenir sur effectivement l'arrogance
les les plus jeunes utilisateurs ils
disent le respect est mort mais là c'est
vraiment on va mettre Sifaoui pendant
une heure c'était le respect est mort il
avait aucun respect pour les questions
qui lui étaient posées qui pour le coup
était tout à fait normal
civil le le enfin j'ai pas vu les
sénateurs montés sur leurs grands
chevaux et devenir insultant et mais lui
par contre il était en permanence mais
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il se sent je
ne sais pas pourquoi mais il est il est
imprégné par une espèce de de d'autorité
que peut-être son réseau lui confère et
qui fait que c'est aussi ça que c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle il a
sûrement accepté l'argent sans sans rien
en faire parce qu'il imaginait que ça
pouvait passer ça pouvait passer crème
pour utiliser une autre expression déjà
voilà c'est très jeune
non mais sur le fond c'est vrai que ça
pose question au moment où on demande
enfin au moment on demande aux Français
de faire des efforts et là on a plus de
300.000 euros qui sont donnés
sans que on sache vraiment où ça va et
ce qui en effet précisément est-ce que
du coup ça peut créer des interrogations
évidemment mais oui alors je vais pas
sombrer dans une démagogie absurde mais
vous savez le la grande question des
Français aujourd'hui c'est de voir que
ce pays paye énormément d'impôts les
ménages les entreprises etc et que dans
le même temps les services publics
s'effondrent donc la question que soit
l'hôpital que ce soit la police la
justice qui manque de moyens donc la
question des Français qui les tarotte
c'est mais où va notre pognon où va
notre pognon et bien c'est évidemment
une goutte d'eau on a 3300 milliards
d'euros 3000 milliards d'euros de dettes
donc c'est mais sur ce fond Marianne de
2 millions et demi d'euros la question
c'est bien celle-là et c'est la même
même si c'est à l'échelle d'un fond de 2
millions et demi d'euros c'est mais
housse tout cet argent passe ben en
réalité l'Etat c'est même pas parce que
le contrôle sur les 2000000 et demi
d'euros il y a une commission d'enquête
au Sénat pour essayer démêler où est
passé l'argent à quoi a-t-il servi et
est-ce qu'il aille bien été utilisé et
du coup ça alimente le fait que les
Français ne font que de se poser cette
question c'est-à-dire mais où va tout
notre argent où va cet argent l'État
n'est pas capable de le et c'est pour ça
qu'il y a une commission d'enquête et je
suis pas certain qu'à l'issue des
travaux de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale on en saura beaucoup plus et
quel a été le rôle de la ministre
qu'elle a été le rôle de Marlène chappe
elle était auditionnée elle aussi
mercredi
cruciale dans les travaux de cette
commission d'enquête avec des questions
autour de voilà cette question autour
d'un dysfonctionnement est-ce que la
ministre a pu favoriser l'association de
Mohamed sefaoui faut archi faux a dit
Marlène Schiappa mercredi en audition et
d'ailleurs elle le dit son directeur de
cabinet à l'époque Sébastien Jallet même
s'il évoqué une courte rencontre entre
elle et mammati dans un couloir de
ministère et bien il n'y avait pas de
favoritisme à la clé écoutez la ministre
monsieur le Préfet j'allais dit j'ai pas
de raison de ne pas le croire que je
suis venu saluer lors d'un rendez-vous
du 22 avril si ma mémoire est bonne
monsieur sia oui c'est tout à fait
probable ça m'arrive fréquemment de
venir saluer de manière par courtoisie
les gens qui sont reçus par les membres
de mon cabinet je n'ai pas souvenir
monsieur le Président de ce que j'ai pu
lui dire très honnêtement au moment de
le saluer mais en tout cas si c'est la
question je ne lui ai pas dit que
j'allais lui attribuer une subvention ou
lui faire attribuer une subvention ça je
ne le fais jamais donc c'est très clair
je n'ai pas le souvenir elle a
régulièrement été sur ce registre alors
de ses réponses au sénateur en tout cas
pour conclure les sénateurs ont terminé
leurs auditions et hier en conclusion de
la dernière audition ils ont dit avoir
relevé je cite un certain nombre de
contradictions entre les déclarations
des uns et des autres au cours des
auditions
Oriane les sénateurs qui remettront leur
rapport qui s'annonce qui s'annonce
accablant ce sera mi-juillet et on
suivra ça Eric Revel est-ce que ça peut
être ravageur vous avez suivi cette
audition de Marlène je sais pas qui
c'est régulièrement des fossés sur son
cabinet elle a pas suivi elle n'était
pas au courant
c'est ravageurs ça pour une mini alors
je vais je vais commencer par vous dire
que
cette audition pour moi de Marianne
Chapat elle a été confuse elle était
alambiqué elle a été marquée de trous de
mémoire alors par moments et souvenais
des choses par moment elle avait
complètement oublié où elle était pas en
capacité de mais évidemment que que ces
ravageurs ça donne le sentiment encore
une fois aux Français qu'il y a pas
grand chose qui est contrôlé y compris
dans un ministère quand on a loue des
fonds parce que Madame Schiappa
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait pendant cette
audition que j'ai suivi aussi avec
beaucoup d'intérêt c'est qu'elle ne
cesse de se défausser sur le comité de
sélection sur son administration sur son
cabinet et quand elle ne le fait pas
quand elle ne se défonce pas bah elle a
des trous les trous de mémoire mais sur
le fond je vais vous dire même si Madame
borne est montée au créneau pour
défendre dans le maintien de Madame
Schiappa au gouvernement je vais te
lèvres oui mais quand même elle l'a fait
mais et l'opposition demande la
démission même je sais pas mais sur le
fond je veux dire une chose mais tout le
monde s'en tape je veux dire que Madame
Schiappa reste au gouvernement ou
qu'elle ne reste pas au gouvernement
c'est pas ça qui changera le quotidien
des Français et c'est pas ça qui
changera l'horizon politique de la
France si vous voulez madame madame
Schiappa on enfer on en fait parce que
le sujet évidemment important encore une
fois parce qu'il y a l'aspect moral et
éthique d'un fond créé en mémoire de
Samuel Paty décapité par un terroriste
islamiste mais sur le fond ça ne
changera ni l'avenir de la politique
française n'est-ce pas ni l'avenir de ce
gouvernement c'est pas parce que Madame
Schiappa serait en difficulté que ce
gouvernement va changer comme on le dit
dans les prochains jours vous voyez donc
je suis un peu un peu dur un peu méchant
mais je vous dis réellement ce que ce
que je pense et cette audition même
Schiappa pour moi elle est nulle et non
avenue c'est à dire que on s'y perdait
on ne comprenait pas je ne comprenais
même pas parfois ce qu'elle racontait
je suis complètement d'accord avec c'est
à dire que c'est vrai que le poids
politique de Marlène Schiappa n'est pas
si important que ça elle a une parole
elle a une elle a une façon en fait de
s'exprimer et un rapport aux Français et
aux Françaises qui lui donne une
certaine singularité et à mon avis qui
justifiait sa place dans dans dans les
gouvernements auxquels elle a participé
là c'est vrai que ça commence à devenir
un peu compliqué mais c'est vrai qu'elle
soit là ou qu'elle soit pas là c'est pas
comme si on part on perdait ou que le
gouvernement allait perdre tout d'un
coup le soutien d'une partie de la
majorité parce que Marlène Schiappa ne
serait plus sa démission ne sert à rien
en revanche je pense qu'elle est quand
même nécessaire pour une question de
probité du du gouvernement c'est-à-dire
je vois pas comment Elisabeth borne ou
le nouveau ou la nouvelle Première
ministre qui qui succédera peut-être
pourrait dire bon bah c'est bon on garde
marine Chapa j'aimerais juste rajouter
quelque chose sur les prestations parce
que tout à l'heure
Eric disait bah oui mais les Français
savent pas où va leur argent quand et on
paye beaucoup d'impôts c'est vrai et
c'est d'autant plus vrai que lorsqu'on
regarde comment enfin ce qui fait la
différence en fait avec il y a il y a 50
ans où on payait à peu près le même taux
d'imposition voir un peu plus faible ce
qui a augmenté c'est justement c'est les
prestations c'est à dire c'est c'est pas
les les traitements des fonctionnaires
ça ça reste à peu près constant c'est
les prestations c'est à dire qu'on donne
de l'argent à des boîtes à des
entreprises privées là en l'occurrence à
des associations pour remplir des
missions de pseudo service public ça se
voit beaucoup notamment dans la santé
les dépenses de santé elles ont augmenté
parce que ce sont les prestations de
prestataires extérieurs qui ont qui ont
augmenté et ça il faut que le contrôle
soit accru en fait sur ce type de de
prestation on ne sait pas toujours ce
qu'ils font on donne x milliers d'euros
ou x millions d'euros et mais hier il
faut qu’il y a un contrôle et là c'est
quand même ça il faut il faut terminer
quand même sur un point positif il y a
quand même le PNF qui qui enquête sur le
marché national financier qui enquête
sur ce qui se passe il y a cette enquête
de enfin ce commission d'enquête
parlementaire d'ailleurs c'est étonnant
qu'il fasse les deux en même temps enfin
maintenant ça a l'air d'être courant
puisque aussi sur Benalla il y en avait
eu deux en même temps qu'ils étudient
pas exactement la même chose
mais ce qui veut dire que les
contre-pouvoirs existent le Parlement
est un contre-pouvoir la justice est un
contre-pouvoir et ils peuvent exercer
des contrôles sur l'action du
gouvernement je vais casser un peu le
point positif avec la dernière question
ericable puisque vous nous avez rappelé
à plusieurs reprises que ce fond il
avait été créé pour lutter contre le le
séparatisme hier Jean-François Husson
qui était là qui est le rapporteur de
cette commission d'enquête il disait en
faisant ce qu'elle a fait Marlène
Schiappa elle a abîmé les valeurs de la
République il y a de ça aussi bah oui
elle est abîmé les valeurs de la
République je pense que et ça a été dit
dans l'audition aussi et jette un
certain discrédit sur le monde
associatif
elle jette un certain discrédits sur mon
associatif parce qu'en réalité quand
vous donnez de l'argent à des
associations ben vous voulez que votre
argent soit bien utilisé c'est normal
quand l'État subventionne des
associations quand des collectivités
locales subventionnelles des
associations on se dit cet argent est
bien utilisé mais d'une certaine manière
pardon mais cette affaire autour de du
fond Marianne jette le discrédit pas
surtout que les associations évidemment
17 dans le fond marin
en tout cas en tout cas je pense que les
gens se posent la question est-ce que
l'argent qui est versé sous forme de
subventions via les collectivités
locales ou via des donations ou des
aides de privé est-ce que cet argent est
bien utilisé et ça c'est une mèche si
vous voulez longue parce qu'en réalité
cette commission d'enquête interroge sur
l'utilisation de ces fonds et donc je
pense que beaucoup de Français se posent
la question aujourd'hui et sachant que
elle est en charge du
associatifs
des amateurs que Macron avait dit soyez
fier d'être des amateurs quand on a des
amateurs avec beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
à distribuer bah ça pose problème
parfois on suivra évidemment les suites
de cette commission d'enquête vous
viendrai j'espère nous en parler vous
restez avec nous le vendredi on part à
la découverte de nos régions et Samia de
chien nous emmène dans le parc des
écrins il fête ses 50 ans au coeur des
Alpes ces montagnes protégées de tout
aménagement abrite une biodiversité
exceptionnelle on regarde
au départ du col du Lautaret le sentier
des crevasses
Cyril coursier le connaît par cœur voilà
25 ans qu'il travaille pour le parc
national des Écrins ce qui me plaît dans
ce métier ben c'est qu'on est voilà on a
un bureau qui est pas trop mal on est
dehors on a une variété une mosaïque de
paysage qui fait que ben on va observer
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup d'espèces
différentes alors que nous sommes quand
même à entre 2000 et 2100 mètres
d'altitude n'est pas loin
si l'on sait les reconnaître on peut
entendre ici des espèces rares comme le
tétralire avec un peu de chanson peut
même l'apercevoir
qui a un aspect noir avec des reflets
des reflets bleutés et là en ce moment
là on est donc au début juin donc on est
encore pour en pleine période de
reproduction si la faune de ce
territoire est si riche c'est qu'elle a
pu évoluer elle est à presque sauvage
depuis 50 ans le statut de parc national
protège les écrins de tout aménagement
en dehors des sentiers refuges c'est un
des rares coins en France
où on peut encore où on peut encore se
perdre c'est un des rares coins en
France où on peut se retrouver au cœur
de la montagne sans ne voir aucun
aménagement humain c'est un des rares
coins en France où on peut
randonner toute une journée sans croiser
personne un site exceptionnel mais en
première ligne face au réchauffement
climatique
chaque année à la même date les agents
photographies se glaciers situés sous la
neige l'un des sommets emblématiques du
parc cette image date de l'été 2000 même
si on est que au mois de juin et qu'il
reste encore beaucoup de neige on devine
que bah voilà la toute cette partie de
glace a déjà bien fondu et pareil à
toute cette langue a déjà déjà est déjà
remonté et ben voilà c'est
c'est inexorable c'est une des preuves
du réchauffement climatique ça les
glaciers fondent nous on ne peut que
constater on n'a pas les moyens de
lutter contre pour étudier les effets du
réchauffement climatique sur la
biodiversité les agents du parc mènent
des recherches scientifiques
d'années en année Cédric domptant suit
l'évolution de certaines espèces comme
le sol nain caché dans les herbes cette
forêt miniature est l'un des meilleurs
témoins de l'état de la flore locale une
manière que les sols ont trouvé pour se
protéger du gel c'est de d'être
recouvert par la neige en gros de se
mettre une couverture nageuse pendant
toutes les périodes de grands froid donc
c'est à dire tout l'hiver parce que
entre la neige et le sol ça ne gèle pas
il fait 0° or si on réduit l'enneigement
s'il y a moins de neige et ben c'est une
espèce qui va être vouée à disparaître
la paire de la biodiversité voilà c'est
pas que le drame de l'ours polaire de la
baleine bleue de la forêt amazonienne
que qui sont très populaires chez nous
parce que loin de nous mais c'est aussi
à côté à côté de à côté de beaucoup
d'habitation des plantes qui qui
plein qui prennent de plein fouet aussi
en fait tous ces changements à la
recherche sur les
2000 espèces végétales du parc des
écrins 150 sont protégés comme la
définition ou encore la vinaigrette
alpine c'est une des rares
carnivore
[Musique]
es qui ont une petite comme une petite
glue sur lequel les insectes viennent se
poser mais on va dire se retrouve piégé
botaniste passionnée Cédric Danton ne
cesse jamais de s'émerveiller de ce
qu'il croise à ses pieds
par rapport à des mêmes des plantes qui
nous ressemblent pas vraiment qui nous
regardent pas et qu'il respire pas comme
nous et ben ça aide justement à se
sentir investi par par leur devenir
aussi et peut-être un peu plus avoir
conscience que notre devenir en dépend
aussi complètement véritable amoureux de
ces montagnes une centaine d'agents du
parc veille chaque jour à la
préservation de ce lieu d'exception et
voilà pour cette très belle image du
parc des écrins signé Samia de Schir
quand on regarde ce qu'elle a une de nos
quotidien régionaux avec plaisir
[Musique]
et on commence avec le plan ruralité
présenté hier par Elisabeth borne voilà
on en parlait au début de cette émission
effectivement avec Bernard delcro c'est
à la une du Dauphiné borne au secours de
nos campagnes avec les annonces de la
première ministre hier pour redynamiser
les communes rurales pour cela le
gouvernement prévoit de sortir le carnet
de chèque écrit Le Dauphiné Libéré
Oriane raconte les coulisses du
processus de négociation sur l'autonomie
de l'île voilà dans les coulisses de ce
processus effectivement c'est à dire
aujourd'hui à la Une de Corse-Matin qui
raconte les échanges entre l'exécutif
Corse et le ministère de l'Intérieur et
d'ailleurs de négociation Oriane dont on
a parlé à l'Elysée nous raconte
l'article dans les pages intérieures
c'était lundi matin et c'est à dire donc
aujourd'hui dans Corse-Matin une
interview du garde des souris
Dupont-Moretti c'est à l'une de Midi
Libre j'assume la fermeté deux pages
spéciales effectivement à lire dans le
Midi Libre aujourd'hui alors que on le
sait Oriane la loi de programmation de
la justice a été adopté au Sénat c'était
cette semaine et la question cruciale de
l'eau c'est à la une du Berry
Républicain bien sûr il y a plus un jour
la sécheresse dans les départements et
bien ne s'invite pas dans cette revue de
presse on en parlait hier avec Audrey
vuettaz et donc là ce matin ce sont les
fuites qui sont traquées cette question
cruciale parce que sur 5 litres d'eau
potable plus d'un litre est perdu avant
qu'on se met sur nous raconte le journal
on en parle dans quelques instants c'est
votre générique Revel on termine avec
les festivals à la Une de Ouest-France
leur transition écologique donc c'est
tout ça cela fait sens ensemble avec à
la Une voyez cette photo du festival de
beau regard c'est en Normandie sur une
photo prise en 2022 et donc des
initiatives pour réduire l'empreinte
carbone de ces rendez-vous de l'été
auquel et bien tiennent beaucoup les
Français dont vous vous irez Quentin
mais bon regarde je suis allé avec un
peu le Bouffard
merci Quentin la une on regarde vos une
la Une de l'hémicycle c'est l'eau on
disait l'eau en jeu vital bah oui c'est
un enjeu vital c'est un enjeu crucial on
peut manquer de pétrole ou d'énergie
fossile mais on peut pas manquer d'eau
en réalité puisque c'est à la base de
absolument en tout c'est l'un des
dossiers spéciaux de l'hémicycle qui
sort en kiosque aussi au mois de juin
donc vous pouvez le retrouver c'est une
très belle revue trimestrielle qui parle
de politique
en essayant d'aborder tous les thèmes
transversaux de la société française
mais pas de manière politicienne
j'allais dire mais vraiment sur le fond
avec l'idée sous-jacente et vous en êtes
un exemple vivant c'est qu'il faut que
les Français s'emparent de nouveau de la
politique aime débattre de la politique
parce que sinon il y a pas de démocratie
de déconstruire en fait ce concept
d'Occident qui est très porté en ce
moment par la par la droite et par
l'extrême droite en gros pour faire
simple et pour résumer on explique que
ça n'existe pas aussi
pabloquer merci Eric Revel et merci
quand tes émissions publiques sénat.fr
ensuite
[Musique]